oh my goodness
he's like the hostage negotiator
[Laughter]
try to keep everybody cool
I wonder if they've never had this
happen before
this is just scary they've been up there
for an hour they're just talking to the
people trying to keep them calm
as of what I've heard from one of our
police officers they have to grind that
guy's grinding some kind of metal steel
thing that's kind of like a safety
switch that's stopped the machine up
there once that gets grinded then it's
gonna fall two three feet and the
operator should be able to release
everything by Hydraulics but they've
never had this happen before so we're
not too sure
there we go I think that's what they're
gonna do
looks like everything's gonna be good
and safe hopefully everybody is uh
is not in too bad of shape